The salons of Paris in the 18th century were where the game was played, where wit was currency and presence was power.
To be invited was to be seen.
But the real art wasn't in the conversation.
It was in the performance of it.
Days spent rehearsing nonchalance, crafting the illusion of effortless brilliance.
The Enlightenment had its thinkers, but the salons had their peacocks.
And now, in the 21st century, we have our own version of that theater.
It's called the LinkedIn Mirage.
Here, the only thing more valuable than your actual achievements is the way you announce them.
Every promotion becomes a humble yet honored milestone.
Every layoff a pivotal chapter of growth.
Every spreadsheet a deep dive into disruptive innovation.
This isn't networking.
It's professional envy made digital and endless scroll of people who are, in their own words, winning,
while you're left wondering why your own life feels like a supporting role in someone else's highlight reel.
The performance begins with what I'll call the announcement protocol.
Never let success be quiet.
Spend more time drafting the post than you did earning the thing itself.
Weave in the obligatory keywords, grateful journey, stewardship,
because the real work isn't the achievement anymore.
It's the social maintenance.
One like, one share, and suddenly your pride isn't yours to keep.
It's a debt to the algorithm, to the feed, to the ghost of professionalism that haunts every profile.
Then comes the comparison audit.
Thirty minutes every morning, scrolling through the feeds of people younger than you,
with titles that sound like they were written by a committee of corporate poets.
Their announcements aren't just brags.
They're benchmarks.
You measure yourself against them, and of course, you lose.
Not because you're failing, but because the game is rigged.
You're comparing your messy, doubtful reality to their curated, highlights-like judging a life by its Instagram story.
And if that weren't enough, there's the endorsement game.
A delicate dance of mutual deception where you swap praise for skills you've never actually practiced.
Expert in AI strategy.
Master of emotional intelligence.
The profile becomes a patchwork of borrowed confidence.
The fear isn't that someone will call you out.
It's that they'll ask you to do it.
Because what happens when the imposter syndrome you've cultivated for years finally meets reality?
Then there's the thought-leadership loop.
A feedback system designed to ensure no one ever has to think too hard.
Early to bed, early to rise, makes a man healthy, wealthy, and disruptive.
The content isn't meant to inform.
It's meant to fill the void.
To make you feel like you're contributing, even as you're drowning in the noise.
The more you post, the more you believe you're leading.
The more you believe, the more you post.
And the cycle continues, until the only thing left is the hollow echo of your own professional echo chamber.
The endgame?
The C-Sweet Shadow.
A person who looks like a leader on paper but feels like a fraud in the mirror.
You've mastered the art of appearing successful, humble, driven, winning, while privately wondering how long it'll take before the cracks show.
You're not just an imposter.
You're a ghost in your own career, smiling for the camera while the real work of self-doubt plays on loop in your head.
And if you need proof, look no further than the Residence Log, October 14th.
The subject, hiding in a bathroom stall, scrolling through a feed of people humbled to announce their latest ascent.
The contrast isn't lost on them.
Neither is the realization that the only thing more exhausting than the grind is the performance of it.
A resume is a list of things you've done.
A LinkedIn profile is a list of things you wish people believed you'd done.
And the worst part, they might just believe it.